Great.
So, now that we've learned the differences between author-driven and
viewer-driven visualizations, let's go through an exercise.
In this exercise, we're going to be analyzing the narrative structure of
different visualizations.
We provided some examples for you, and we want you to
ask four simple questions and write your answers in the discussion form.
First, we want to know what is the narrative structure of
the visualization that you've chosen?
Secondly, how does the visualization lead you through the data?
Third question is,
what is the story being told with this particular visualization?
And last, how could this have been improved?
Please pick a visualization from the examples provided, and
answer these four questions in a discussion form.